eeuu y méxico se comprometieron a
abordar las causas más profundas que
originan la violencia en su frontera
binacional la alianza se enfocará en
prevenir la delincuencia transfronteriza
combatiendo el tráfico de armas y la
trata de personas por medio del
fortalecimiento de la justicia además
buscará invertir en educación y salud
pública para frenar el impacto del uso
de drogas
sí
de santander las causas
los planes que hay quizás
de una cooperación en cada pacto de
alianza es algo distinto de sus
superiores 40 millones
solamente en tres días con alguien de
equipo y
ambos gobiernos anunciaron el fin de la
iniciativa mérida la estrategia de
seguridad que estaba vigente desde el
2008 con enfoque militar
en el marco del centenario méxico eeuu
para la seguridad la salud pública y las
comunidades seguras también se trabajará
en la reducción de tráfico de armas la
producción de drogas químicas y la
seguridad internacional en el
ciberespacio las nuevas estrategias
entrarán en vigor en 2022 al cumplirse
200 años de relaciones bilaterales entre
ambas naciones
la relación entre nuestros gobiernos es
compleja todos los días estamos
trabajando juntos en problemas como el
clima la salud pública la educación
pública y el turismo
y
mantener esa relación y mantener el
diálogo en cada nivel que requiere
aprovechar las oportunidades y
adaptarnos a nuevos retos eso es
exactamente lo que hicimos hoy
ah
y las nuevas estrategias entrarán en
vigor en 2022 al cumplirse 200 años de
relaciones bilaterales entre ambas
naciones